[Musique]
c'est une première session sous le signe
de l'intelligence artificielle qui a
pris fin
nous avons réuni les actuels et futurs
étudiants en universitaires pour un
bilan ça change complètement la manière
dont on mène son apprentissage ça va
vraiment faire partie de notre futur
est-ce que vous avez utilisé
ou si oui comment faire du péter pour
moi c'est exactement que Wikipédia une
source que tu peux utiliser quand tu
veux en apprendre davantage sur un sujet
je suis une peureuse je voulais pas être
attrapé avec la fraude je connais
beaucoup d'amis qui vont utiliser
c'était très bénéfique pour l'université
je vais y penser
selon des chiffres préliminaires 22% des
étudiants universitaires ont utilisé
rarement parfois souvent ou toujours si
nous vous outils ces derniers mois ça
fait gagner un temps fou parce qu'au
lieu d'aller chercher moi-même des
informations qui se complètent entre
elles ça fait un condensé qui qui me
fait gagner un temps vraiment important
j'ai des collègues qui l'ont utilisé
puis il y a plein de manières d'utiliser
de manière qui sont plus légitimes de
manière qui sont un peu plus
problématiques et j'ai aussi vu des gens
qui copient directement sans citer sans
les méthodes de détection sont pas
encore développées je dirais que les
gens cessaient beaucoup dites ça les
étudiantes sont à l'université au cégep
mais la plupart sont très conscients que
s'ils font juste s'user chaque GPT dans
leur travaux il y a tiendront pas ces
connaissances là puis seront pas
outillés sur le marché du travail tout
le monde est dépassé par cet événement
là c'est un ami qui cette experte en
intégrité académique confirme qu'il y a
de bonnes et de mauvaises manières
d'utiliser l'intelligence artificielle
générative ce qu'on veut c'est que les
étudiants se servent de cet outil là
comme aide à la rédaction et non pas
comme outil de rédaction un outil de
rédaction c'est du plagiat un outil
d'aide à la rédaction ça peut être tout
à fait intégré quand vous voulez et
c'est ce qu'elle s'applique enseigner
aux centaines de professeurs qu'elle a
rencontré dans les derniers mois lors de
formation aux quatre coins de la
province et ne mise pas sur les outils
de détection de l'IA qui ne sont pas
pour le moment suffisamment fiables
selon elle la seule façon qu'on peut
être certains à 100% que l'étudiant a
utilisé l'intelligence Cécile avoue
l'avoir fait certaines universités comme
lucasme sont aussi sceptiques quant à la
capacité de logiciel de détection de
l'IA de prévenir la fraude
d'entrer dans une course aux armements
avec l'intelligence artificielle et de
chercher par tous les moyens la contrer
d'autres universités sont davantage
intéressées l'Université de Montréal est
en discussion avec des fournisseurs qui
préparent des outils de détection du
plagiat nouvelle génération à la fois il
y a ces changements technologiques là
qui amènent des inconforts sociétales
mais en même temps il y a des
technologies qui sont aussi des réponses
les outils de détection vont jouer un
rôle mais en réalité ce qui est
important c'est de faire évoluer
l'évaluation si on demande de faire un
travail collaboratif d'imaginer des
choses de faire de l'application des
choses comme ça déjà là on se distingue
de ce que tu as jippi ces outils là
peuvent faire
et souvent c'est des biens meilleurs
évaluations que les professeurs fassent
évoluer les évaluations voilà ce que les
étudiants souhaitent aussi inverser son
eau doit demander à son corps
professoral d'adapter ses méthodes
d'évaluation puis de garder une posture
une posture d'ouverture d'esprit il faut
pas seulement en avoir peur oui il y a
différents enjeux là éthiques qui
viennent avec l'intelligence
artificielle mais si c'est enseigné de
la bonne façon si c'est encadré sans la
restreindre mais ça va faire en sorte
que une utilisation intègre est possible
bref rien ne sert de se mettre la tête
dans le sable selon notre panel étudiant
ça fait juste l'interdire qu'est-ce qui
va arriver ben c'est des personnes
étudiantes qui l'utilisent pas puis qui
sont honnêtes dans leur démarche mais
les autres pénalisés nous les gens qui
ont appris à l'utiliser une manière
furtive on va dire vont être favorisés
puis c'est pas ce qu'on veut à mes
collègues étudiants de commencer à
l'utiliser le plus rapidement possible
mais je pense que ça va devenir chose
commune donc si on veut attraper la
vague il faut commencer maintenant c'est
trop utile pour s'en priver en tant
qu'étudiant je pense que c'est comme
toutes les nouvelles technologies c'est
comme toutes les grandes avancées
scientifiques aller à contre-courant ça
ça sert à rien il faut vraiment
travailler avec se former pour
l'utiliser au mieux il faut que les lois
suivent ils savent qu'il y aura de la
résistance de la part de plusieurs
professeurs mais ils sont résolus et
unanimes mieux vaut intégrer si nous
vous outils et apprendre à les maîtriser
dès maintenant avant de se faire
dépasser par la machine ici Fanny
Bussière Nicole Radio-Canada Montréal